I'm going to review let's start with a
little bit of review we talked about
Cree main Jewish denominations in a
previous chapter you guys remember what
those work offhand yeah so we'll put
them left to right for reasons perform
well Orthodox and what else we're going
to talk about them today they're going
to fit in the Orthodox spectrum you guys
remember the one that was it's kind of a
little throw you because normally we
expect that trend to mean that they're
over on this side they're actually the
middle position between reform and
Orthodox I need to remember what the
third one here very good see and
historically the reform are the ones to
have the first sort of you know hardcore
identity as such because they're they're
taking ideas of the Enlightenment and
they're applying them to the Jewish
religion and then the Orthodox are the
ones who just keep on doing the same
things before and the reform of the ones
calling an orthodox originally and then
the conservative about sort of mediating
influence between the now those are the
big Jewish denominations there is two
others that we we left out one calls
itself a denomination the other one
really doesn't call itself is in
operation so one of the ones that we
left out would be the Reconstructionist
and in many ways the reason why I put
them out of spectrum like this in many
ways the reconstruction is there even
further the more radical than Reform
Jews although they come out of the
conservative movement they sort of
swinging way over what if the docs
Judaism is a little bit more complex
than we would
we were thick and the Hasidic kind of
fit over here also you know the ones
that would fit over here would be this
is sort of the key at all term already
which means that those who fear God
Orthodox these are the ones that are
sometimes called ultra-orthodox they are
very strict about things and then we
have a modern orthodox there's all the
terms that get thrown in here to like
your Shiva's Jews not everything is as
you know neat and cut and dries and
presenting here but this kind of gives
you the big idea and we're mostly
interested today in thinking about these
where these guys come from and what's
what's distinctive about them and then
we'll talk about what's going on thank
you know demographically with Judaism in
America and we'll talk about culture how
Judaism has a lot of effect on American
culture so your book starts out talking
about reconstruction ism and like I said
it was outgrowth of the conservative
movement this guy Mordecai Kaplan was a
professor at Jewish Theological Seminary
and he writes this book Judaism as a
civilization and some of the key ideas
in that text are that God is not
personal doesn't mean that God doesn't
take things personally or that you know
God you can't really bother God or
something like that it means God is not
personal that's a radical departure from
the traditional conception of God isn't
it what's the traditional concept of God
don't just say personal because sorry
said that what does it mean for god to
be personal what does that mean for
religious believers yeah
yeah personal person exactly so God is a
person and just like I'm talking with
you we're now engaged in a dialogue and
not actually talking I'm talking process
of teaching and talking to other
students but you and I are like having a
one-on-one right now at least for a
moment that's a personal connection
right after class somebody sticks around
we shoot the breeze about something
that's a personal connection what are
you doing when you pray you're you're
interacting with something that's
supposed to actually care about you as a
person otherwise why do it there's a lot
of things that would go along with
changing the conception of God right now
they did there are reasons to pray
besides that but that that's something
to think about the Jews are not a chosen
people that's a big one too isn't it
because traditional Jewish ideas the
Jews are chosen people so better for
worse as a matter of fact a lot of times
they're not happy to be a chosen people
because it means that everybody else
gets to screw around and do whatever
they want but you know they're supposed
to follow the kosher laws or they've got
this you know this God it gets angry
with them if they don't do the right
things sometimes being chosen isn't
always best some of some of you may be
able to relate to that an individual
levels you were the smart kid who had to
get the good grades or the artistic kid
or whatever your family put on you
sometimes being chosen is now he's great
how should we understand Judaism that he
says Judaism is best understood as a
complex of culture and tradition d ism
is a complex culture and tradition and
you might say well what good are the
traditions well they're supposed to
reveal things to us you know think about
it for example Passover what you know
we've talked about this before what
happens at the
Neil people should get together and put
the feet on the table and say hey
haven't seen you for a year how you bet
that might be Thanksgiving although I
didn't know anyone puts their food on
the table of thanksgiving but you get
the idea what happens if passover people
pray and do they just make up whatever
prayers they want Oh God let this be the
year that we finally hit the jackpot
that would be an appropriate thicker
open it what do they praying about what
do they remember what would pass go yeah
that's pretty serious stuff isn't that
the Angel of Death that killed all the
firstborn during the exodus passed over
the Hebrews and didn't kill all the
firstborn because they sprinkled the
blood of the Lamb that's part of why the
am a lamb at Passover there's a lot of
things too involved in this a lot of
christian easter rituals are derived
from the passover as a matter of fact of
eastern orthodox church is called poss
which means passover originally Last
Supper was a Passover meal all of that
would just be a bunch of cultural
traditions that a person could still
find meaningful but wouldn't have any
literal value you know a
reconstructionist Jew and say well I
mean there's no such thing as angels of
death but we can still get some meaning
out of this it can still matter to us
and eventually there they become a whole
movement they're able to open up the
reconstruction of rabbinical college
like it says the tradition was beginning
to modify its early the emphasis on the
supernatural by including references to
biblical miracles the Messianic age and
it's recently revised her book but most
reconstructionist Jews understand these
is symbolic or mythical they're just
allen words they're supposed to tell us
something
you can tell that they're pretty far in
on a literal spectrum because they also
talked about the Patriot a the major
acts as well as the patriarchs you got
to do a bit of digging for that but
there's plenty of female characters in
the Bible they can't stand out but that
sort of thing like you know ask there
and Ruth and people like that there's
even a female judge liking out her name
right now but you know she led Israel in
fighting now we swing all the way to the
other side specific years so the Hasidic
movement begins in the 18th century and
so they're kind of you know an offshoot
from the Orthodox before the Orthodox
call themselves organized and it's
mostly happening in Eastern Europe and
the Hasidic Jews are reacting against
what they feel is that sort of top-down
rabbi in charge sterile religious
experience that they're having what they
want to have instead is a more direct
connection with with God through daily
life something that doesn't require you
to study Talmud to go off to some sort
of yeshiva or a rabbinical school and
you know spend years and years doing
that something that the ordinary person
could relate to it doesn't mean they
don't have religious figures they do in
fact have have you know rabbits rabbis
teachers and then there's the India the
role of somebody who is called sock this
is translated as Saint and this would be
a holy person who is so in touch with
God that they're very contact or
presence it's sort of you know M&E
godliness it goes so far with some where
they'll actually save the crumbs from a
meal that this person has you know
because somehow though when I call me
the aura of sanctity connects with them
but they were really interested in like
it says a very down-to-earth extremely
traditional Jewish piety also ecstatic
singing dance you know
your book talks about this is a total
immersion style of Orthodox Judaism in
which all other considerations are
subordinated to the imperative leading
is purely religious life as possible so
one key thing is the sanctification of
everyday life everything that a person
can do that person does can be an act of
worship Hasidic neighborhoods possess
all the material needs restrict
observance of synagogues you need a
place to go religious schools keep its
bookstores kosher restaurants and
butcher shops and a bathhouse now why
would you need a bath house well because
the traditional you know Jewish law says
that there are certain times when a
woman actually has to bake ritual and
these were things that you could find in
ancient Israel because they were known
as part of the law and you can find
these in acidic neighborhoods as well
your book talks about some of the
divisions between them but it doesn't
tell you much about them so I'm actually
going to sort of skip over that one of
the things I do want to talk about your
book doesn't want very much since we are
in this area is you you've all seen I
think you know whether you've been to
neighborhoods are not considered Jewish
families in transit you go anywhere
along the interstates and stop at rest
areas you see them right how can you
tell the 30 Civic Jews as opposed to say
Reform Jews or conservative Jews what's
distinctive yeah they're wet dress
yeah now the way of dress is actually
there's nothing you know necessary that
it you know biblical or something like
that for the most part I mean covering
the Hat and that sort of stuff is but
it's derived from 17th and 18th century
Eastern Europe they adopted a particular
way of dress and that is continued
through I need to make with nicer
material or you know cheaper material
depending on your taste you can innovate
to some degree but for the most part
it's you know I mean it's almost always
a white shirt right and black dark pants
black jacket half and then the four
lines whatever that's again part of the
traditional Jewish piety symmetries
aren't the only wants to do that the sum
of the Orthodox who are not just sitting
also do that but they're the ones that
you're asking more and more this is
where we get to talking about
demographics what is the bargain
moderately is a study of people at
numbers so if we're talking about growth
in one community and decline in another
community that's demography talking
about your generation of college
students as being twice the size of my
generation that's demography as well
generation access was reliable auctions
is half the size of the other two
generations boomers and you guys where
does grow taking place in the Jewish
community right now Reform Jews are the
largest group of religious Jews there
are there are a lot of Jews who are not
religious at all just ethnically jewish
these are the largest conservative an
orthodox depending on how you parse the
numbers on conservative the mic a little
bit more them at this time than the
north adopts
where do you think growth is taking
place it's very similar to what we saw
it with Protestant may my Protestants of
conservative protestants where where is
growth taking place reform and the
Reconstructionist not really if you have
traditional gender roles and you stress
fertility acidic families tend to have
on average you know anywhere from 2-6
sometimes more kids that's a very large
growth rate acidic jewish populations
double and I forget exactly how long
this it's pretty priesthood it's a
pretty small things every generation so
they're growing the Orthodox Jewish
population is growing as well there was
a really interesting study that was
released a while back called will our
children be Jewish and the question was
what is Judaism going to look like 10 20
30 40 years from now over your lifetime
conservative reform reconstructionist
Jews are not reproducing that rates
necessary to maintain the community in
addition there's one other thing is
really important to keep in mind we
talked about this in terms of the
Eastern Orthodox intermarriage when you
intermarry there's always questions
about if you marry somebody from a
different religion question what are we
going to do with the kids are we going
to send them if you're Orthodox we're
going to sell them to Hebrew school are
they going to learn in the traditions
with leaving the practice cells or are
we gonna sort of like say well wait
until you're 18 that you can decide for
yourself which is basically saying to
the kids you're not gonna practice
anything because most kids at 18 years
old are not out there you know trying
out all the different religious altering
this I'm trying out all the other
alternatives right Reform Jews
conservative Jews interim area that
pretty significant
and a lot of their kids are probably not
going to be brought up Jewish so these
populations are shrinking pretty quickly
about six and a half million Jews in
United States radius as time goes on
we're going to see this part of them
become predominant and this part not
completely disappear but but become you
know much smaller sort of like we've
seen a lot of the mainline Protestant
denominations lose a lot of the
membership and grew a lot older over the
last you know 30 40 years that's an
important thing to keep in mind your
book talks about the other the other
denominations and there are sort of
fortunes but I want to skip half step
your book that also talks about
institutional forms for Jewish life and
these are institutions that you've
probably come into contact role to some
degree or another because they're
they're important like the you know
United Jewish communities which is a
fundraising essentially a humanitarian
charitable organization but I breathe
the anti-defamation league allow
foundation American Jewish Committee
American Jewish Congress these are all
ways in which organizations Jewish
people and have a role in American
public life when we get to chapter 27
we're talking about culture and
economics and to a lesser degree
politics and then chapter begins by
saying to be Jewish in 21st century
America involves making choices more so
perhaps than for any other religious
group now why do they say that why let's
say you are Jewish why does being Jewish
and he'll making choices
well first you got to figure out where
should I be these are these are not
compatible you can't be Orthodox and
perform at the same time Kenya you might
actually have to decide it am I going to
be religious at all that could be a
first tries to get to me if you are
going to be religious how are you going
to understand your religiosity are you
going to follow all 613 of the mitzvot
not all and actually would apply to you
you know for instance I the one server
for you you know you guys you wouldn't
have to worry about bathing after
menstruation right because issue not I
mean hopefully they get leprosy so that
that's probably not going to be a bit
spot that you would have to worry about
but the rest of them can be pretty
onerous there's a lot you have to do
it's tough to live this kind of
lifestyle we're needs you to terrorize
something that is primarily an ethical
code ceremonial stuff is this you being
is there still prejudice against Jews in
some quarters here in America can you
still find some people talking about the
protocols of the Elders of Zion and
Jewish conspiracy things like that just
type it in at Google you get a lot of
sites there are a lot of people still
believing this result by the way the
protocols for the auto design was
actually a forged document plagiarized
from a imaginary dialogue between two
French philosophers one Italian
philosopher and another prejudice
originally written in French that's sort
of the back story of why was there
prejudice against Jews what reforms did
it take we've talked about this a little
bit before this is just because they're
other different we don't you know as
human beings we don't like different
people
so if Christianity is the predominant
religion or Protestant Christianity or
evangelical protestant christianity is
the fidelity of religion they're just
not go let anyone else in these are the
things that are worth we're thinking
about what we do know is that there's
two things going on at the same time on
the one hand Jews come to America did in
fact for the most part do quite well and
they did quite well in part because
where they ended up New York City for
example talk about why in a moment but
also because of certain cultural
emphasis on the other hand they also ran
into projects they ran into quota
systems they ran into closed doors and
this led to an interesting kind of
situation but first let's talk about why
they where they did well liked your book
tells you entry into academic and
professional life in New York City was
facilitated by something what would that
be those of you are from the city what
do you know about the new york city and
i don't want to say the state college
because then you think of sunni think
about q why was it so attractive for
recent immigrants how so
yeah I mean it actually does cost money
to go there now right oh yeah but used
to be free if you were a resident you
could go into college for free just
imagine that think about how much
somebody's paying not you necessarily
all you may be taking out loans could be
your parents could be the government
could be somebody think my how much
they're paying for you to go here and
the doors this is opening up for you now
think about the fact that you could if
you lived in New York City if you were
an immigrant I became a resident you
could go to college for free all you had
to do is demonstrate the aptitude you
had to be able to you know demonstrate
that you use ecology materials and many
people want college material so like a
book points out Jews were perceived by
many Gentiles as the perennial Outsiders
simultaneously strange and familiar like
a lot of other other people's from
eastern mediterranean origin they were
they were adapted by temperament and
experience for success in a commercially
oriented culture where education
enterprise and adaptability all confused
towards material reward so we've got two
things going on here we've got a
religious and ethnic group that is
really on the go we have a lot of
barriers occurring saying we're not
going to let you in you can't go here
you can't work in this field so what
happens as a result what would you do if
you're in a situation like that hey I
should put this on
yeah education drive normally oh right
right that would normally leads a
success and at the same time barriers
and exclusions you guys have probably
experienced things like this there are
things that you wanted to do in your
life and somebody said no you can't do
it you can't be a part of our club you
you can't be in our other thing we've
already taken up the space you don't get
to do that so what do you do in a
situation like that you really actually
do have a passion to succeed you just
flow ok i'm done i'll go away is that
what you do I hope not because this is
not an Academy for that sort of thing
what do you do you get Adam throw rocks
who you key on people's cars that's not
going to be a particularly successful
response either what would you do right
if you have faced that sort of situation
what do you do like they've barred you
from swimming come on like girls with
brown hair anymore you know they don't
get to swim we just take it what would
you do here you'd probably go to any
like you know some administrator and say
hey this is unfair and let's say the
administrator said well life is unfair
get used to this is part of your
education okay and you might transfer
you would find an alternative place to
go right so one one response to this was
sort of tension is to create alternate
opportunities
would you consider doing another sport
maybe it's funny they didn't have crazy
rules like that what if it could be kind
of like slow swimmers ours are extremely
athletic everywhere because you get
training almost the hardest of all the I
think you probably couldn't answer you
can also you know get him on new fields
whether there are no limits so how does
this occur well you know in cases where
like you know legal firms or clothes
manufacturers Jews opened up their own
businesses their own firms they you know
they created an entire alternative
economic market place and they did very
well they did their with educational
institutions as well there were also new
fields in terms of American culture that
were coming on the scene where they
could get you in like your book says on
the proverbial ground floor and nobody
had set down any limits and said no no
you can't be involved here what were
those sorts of things your book talks
about the motion picture industry for
example why aunt why did so many Jews go
to Hollywood because it was a place
where they could go and they were on the
same level playing field as everybody
else or organizational capacity drive
tale of those sorts of things could
actually be rewarded this by the way is
not something unique to Jewish well this
is something that other ethnicities have
done as well but they were in sort of
the right place at the right time put
quite a few of these things
you're booked on your book kind of jumps
around in this chapter and talks about a
number of different different key issues
of Jewish identity the next thing it
talks about is yet and we've talked
about this before Yiddish was a dialect
of german sort of like Ladino is a
dialect of the Spanish Portuguese at the
time they've spoken when Sephardic Jews
Yiddish is spoken by the Ashkenazim and
most Jews that use Yiddish terms today
don't actually speak yes it's become
your book is this great term for this a
host vernacular language the vernacular
is the language we speak right so the
English that we speak is not completely
proper English I think I don't where to
go to find proper English these days
that's our fern Acula Yiddish used to be
a vernacular like that it's not so much
used like that anymore but a lot of
words have patched into our language
what are some yet ish words your book
brings up genta what's a Yenta maybe
knocking some busybody a gossip
kibitzing is like offering unsolicited
advice if you say somebody's a schmuck
you guys familiar with that term
person's a schmuck do you know that's a
bad word all right it's coming from
yiddish we don't use this one too much
anymore but you know a show meal sort of
a dumb person unfortunate these are all
things that have made their way into
then your book talks about high culture
and when we talk about high culture we
mean literature the arts film can be
high culture right lot you know a lot a
lot of film gets gets put in that
category and what gives you a lot of
examples you know ranging from elie
wiesel
to solve bello talking about literature
they talk about the involvement at the
entertainment industry music number of
other things as well I want to skip over
that and talk about two other things
that you book mansions in this chapter
what does Kabbalah and this this guy
kind of popularized again he's probably
a little bit before your time you
remember who we should have brought it
back on the scene she got into it pop
star she's an aging pop star still out
there singing and dancing and doing a
thing share you say no that's a good
guess though because that sure might
actually be old enough to be your
great-grandmother now this way yeah done
but i'ma get into the Kabbalah chair
might be intuitive for all I know and
then when Madonna gets into something a
lot of people get into something yeah
this is this a couple years back what is
the Gabon spring the Kamal is this this
mystical tradition within Judaism which
really get started in the Middle Ages
and it's it's taking the traditional
Jewish tax and some other esoteric tax
and it's about you know sort of
self-discovery liberating your true self
getting in touch with God we talk about
mysticism we mean some sort of
unsaleable unexpressible way of getting
at reality and so there's this whole
thing how many of you ever seen hi the
movie pi i by the guy just didn't know
one no not the wife about that's good
plan out the distinction life applies
both is this kid on the raft right
tiger this gives a movie hi about the
number pi which is actually known as
boring as it sounds it's the first film
by the guy who just did the no I'm
blanking on his name anybody remember my
pan he's not a lot of other things
requiem for a dream all those things
that movie is about the Cabal if you
want to know why some of the weird
things that are happening at the Noah
movie are happening they're taking from
some of their texts we should remember
his name just throw names out there at
random so that's one one thing to think
about another thing is it talks about
politics who do you know which way did
the Jewish revolt usually go it actually
kind of breaks down I wish out and erase
this is starting to break down a long
lines of denominations Orthodox Jews
tend to go more Republican conservatives
through through reconstructionist
roofing hardcore Democrat used to be
that the Democrats were the party for
the non Protestant establishment people
but if you're at all traditional look
the Republicans have done a good job if
they've done this with Catholics to of
attracting the votes of social
conservatives your book talks about a
number of Jews representing states with
large Jewish constituencies have
achieved distinction in Congress you
know Lieberman would be a prime example
Lieberman ISM Modern Orthodox Jew he was
the Democratic Party candidate for vice
president quite a long time ago with Al
Gore and then he actually sort of
crossed lines a bit as well
politics so yeah there we go there been
a couple key issues that have been very
divisive in the role of Israel whether
we should be supporting this real it's
not something that Jewish opinion is
uniform and it gets debated quite a bit
Jews have played a major role in a lot
of different causes and if what gives
you examples ranging across the
ideological spectrum from you know the
Communist Party all the way to
neoconservative is so all the way from
left to right why do they have such an
important role well you know a lot of
that has to do with this sort of thing
of having education having dry coming
from a tradition that stresses the role
of being articulate ethical obligations
those sorts of things so that's where
we'll close we are now finished with
brawl from tents and purposes with
Judaism and oh I won't see you have a
good had a good easter break imagine a
lot of you going home to your families
so safe travels and have a good time